bratensoße aus der tüte geht schnell und
fast ohne rindfleisch
0,5 prozent
da ist das ja schon weg nach einem
löffel soße sebastian 8 fleisch pulver
selber und zeigt wie knorr bei saucen
spart
er weiß wie kompliziert so eine
bratensoße ist knochenresten
wurzelgemüse rösten tomatenmark
mitrösten rotwein ablöschen wasser drauf
kochen lassen gewürze einkochen lassen
kochen lassen kochen lassen händler
können tage vergehen und hier super
einfach
alles wasser drauf fertig ist die
bratensoße und mit intensiven
fleischgeschmack
voller saucen geschmack zum anrühren
sebastian lee gezeigt wie dieses
kunststück möglich ist zuerst kümmert er
sich um den fleischgeschmack in diesem
pulver
[Musik]
wir erwarten ja eine
kräftige soße
die schmeckt wie der sonntagsbraten und
da darf er einzig füllen
rindfleisch pulver unterstellen wir
jetzt mal her
sebastian lege setzt auf baumscheiben
vom rind sie sind günstig im einkauf und
kräftig im geschmack
im ersten schritt macht er daraus
hackfleisch um die oberfläche zu
vergrößern
[Musik]
sogar das knochenmark kommt bei ihm als
preiswerter geschmacksverstärker mit in
die fleischmasse gerade hier im
knochenmark steckt der pure rindfleisch
geschmack hier ist so viel
gutes fett und eiweiß drin die wir
nachher zu geschmacks intensivierung
brauchen
[Musik]
das kind gleich so bauer ich bin erst
wurde das was da draußen ist
ein bisschen freue ich mich darauf
die lebensmittelindustrie hat
traditionelles trocknen von fleisch
weiterentwickelt ihr ziel fleisch pulver
als grundlage für einen preiswerte
bratensoße
schön dünn aufstreichen war so verkürzen
wir die trockenzeit
auch das trocknen kostet geld die
energie die eigen gesetzt wird und und
und jeder verarbeitungsschritt kostet
geld deswegen versucht man das so extrem
zu verkürzen dass man genügend masse pro
stunde durch jagd nur dann verdient man
geld
die industrie setzt auf riesige
geschlossene anlagen zum trocknen von
fleisch sebastian lege bild zeigen wie
die arbeiten und hat seine ganz eigene
maschine entwickelt marke eigenbau und
absolut transparent das prinzip ist ganz
simpel hier oben ist die wärme hier wird
die warme luft abgesaugt mit der
feuchtigkeit vom fleisch das ganze
kondensiert hier in dem radiator der
ständig gekühlt wird und die trockene
luft geht wieder zurück und das ganze in
dem kreislauf wärme
feuchte luft wird abgesaugt kondensiert
im radiator geht zurück als trockene
luft und schiebt das ganze im kreis aber
immer hin und her
konstant gekühlt perfekt getrocknet
kalte luft kann weniger wasserdampf
aufnehmen als heiße diesen
physikalischen effekt macht sich
sebastian lege zunutze
trocknungs apparat arbeitet zwei stunden
lang und funktioniert aus frischen
rinderhack fleisch wird mit viel energie
dünnes fleisch papier es ist immer noch
hin fleisch
getrocknet und fein vermahlen ist es
monatelang hart und noch etwas macht
fleisch pulver für die industrie so
interessant pulver lassen sich in der
fabrik extrem genau dosieren wichtig
wenn an der teuren zutat gespart wird
knaus bratensoße enthält nämlich gerade
mal 0,5 prozent rindfleisch plündern
0,5 prozent
da ist das ja schon weg nach einem
löffel soße das würde aber ein trockener
sonntagsbraten die industrie hat noch
einen besonderen krieg bereit um fleisch
im kampf keines pulver zu verwandeln
deswegen
war richtig kräftig salz drauf
na klar
ich möchte aroma sparen und teure zutat
mit einer prise salz mehr schmeckt es
richtig schön intensiv
was in den kräftige bratensoße braucht
auch stunden lang gekocht
ihr kollege salz
das salz dient als geschmacksträger
außerdem als mal hilfe
die salzkristalle zerreiben das
rindfleisch pulver ganz ein es entsteht
ein aromatisiertes salz das nach
belieben dosiert werden kann
der riese das kind
die ganzen grob
anteile werden ausgesiebt
unser rindfleisch als wäre dann schon
mal gemacht
[Musik]
jetzt noch die anderen geschmacksstoffe
dazu und
fertig ist unser kleiner button würde
tomaten pulver aromen zucker dazu
gewürze und rückt zwiebeln alles als
pulver alles möglichst sparsam dosiert
jetzt hefeextrakt damit das bisschen was
drin ist auch noch mal richtig den turbo
boost verpasst bekommt
hefeextrakt enthält jede menge blut
einen geschmacksverstärker auf der
zutatenliste steht dann hefeextrakt und
auf der packung ohne
geschmacksverstärker ein ganz legaler
trick und dass er ist palmfett pulver
salz umfeld sind die träger von dem
ganzen würfel und hier nicht so wenig
und das fett kann man auch nicht mehr
sehen weil es mit der stärke ab gebunden
ist klar und wir denken auch was für
eine schöne intensive kräftige soßen
tropfen öl
wir haben es gleich
wir müssen auf dich
perfekt
ja super
da ist
mein instant bratensoße pulver
salz und geschmacksverstärker billiger
lässt sich die basis für eine braune
soße nicht herstellen die 0,5 prozent
rindfleisch pulver fallen kostenmäßig
kaum ins gewicht
billig für die industrie praktisch für
zu hause mit instant pulver kann
wirklich jeder im handumdrehen so zu
kochen sebastian lee gerührt original
und nachbarn seine soße ist etwas heller
sonst hat er das original erstaunlich
gut getroffen
ja sowieso sie zu beraten eine kleine
brise rindfleisch pulver binder farbe
fertig muster seien
die produkte mit dem pulver trick
bringen unilever seit jahrzehnten hohe
renditen
dabei stehen die praktischen töten wegen
ihrer inhaltsstoffe schon lange in der
kritik
[Musik]
natürlich kann man solche produkte mal
einsetzen wenn es wirklich schnell gehen
soll und wenn ich keine zeit habe noch
viele gewürze zusammenzusuchen generell
sollte man diese produkte aber auch
nicht so häufig zu sich nehmen weil sie
hoch verarbeitet sind und teilweise auch
viele gehärtete fette zum beispiel
enthalten das sollte man auch eher
meiden an guten zutaten spart knorr
immer wieder die pilze beim pasta snack
enthält gerade mal 21 prozent pilze
die spargelsuppe 67 prozent weißen
spargel und 1,8 prozent grünen spargel
und in der gemüsebrühe stecken
zusammengerechnet gerade mal zwölf
prozent gemüse stattdessen enthält das
pulver hauptsächlich salz
kraft in den keller klar auf den tisch
selbst früh auf topstars franz
beckenbauer die extrem salzige suppe
wird als kräftige brühe vermarktet er
sagt kraft in den teller knock auf den
tisch
unilever bedient mit knorr einen
weiteren kundenwunsch korn soll ganz
einfach sein von wien ist es ein mega
trend unserer gesellschaft wir wollen
mal zeiten schnell zubereiten und knorr
peter sehr viele möglichkeiten an dass
wir kleinere mahlzeit mit relativ wenig
aufwand selbst zubereiten können
leicht zu essen leider aber nicht
besonders gesund das gilt für viele
produkte von unilever egal ob salzig
oder süß
[Musik]
hey und wenn euch unsere videos gefallen
und ihr nicht genug gehen könnt von
unserem besser ist dann gibt es hier
noch mehr videos und las amazon
abonnieren -button da ich würde mich
freuen bis bald